salut je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
d'une étude scientifique qui confirme et
explique comment on peut déduire la
pensée d'une personne en regardant dans
ses yeux avec les siens donc si vous la
regardez dans les yeux c'est que elle
aussi donc si sfr vous fassiez attention
dans une vidéo du mois de juin je vous
avez aussi parlé d'une étude qui remet
était largement en question la direction
du regard dans l'interprétation qu'on
avait la pnl pas le groupe même s'ils
ont une chanson qui s'appelle je
comprends pas et donc je vous avais
proposé qu'on refasse l'étude
ensemble vous et moi j'ai les résultats
je vous donnais tout ça dans la deuxième
partie de la vidéo parenthèse rapide en
trois mois on est déjà à la septième
édition du livre
c'est clairement un succès et c'est
clairement grâce à vous que j'en ai
aujourd'hui il est considéré comme un
outil pratique et ludique par un bon
nombre de professionnels et particuliers
arts profite de cette vidéo de rentrée
pour vous dire merci
et pour ceux qui souhaitent en savoir
plus dans la description il ya un lien
vers le livre est vers la vidéo de
présentation le 15 juin de cette année
donc 2017 alors oui je donne l'année
pour ceux qui regardent ray cette vidéo
dans 15 ans en se demandant ce que
regarder leurs parents avant parce que
c'est ça qui va se passer un jour en
juin dernier le cnrs le centre national
de recherche scientifique a publié un
communiqué de presse qui s'intitule ce
que les pupilles nous disent sur le
langage depuis longtemps peut-être
toujours où je sais pas quand parce que
je trouve pas forcément de date
au début de cette pratique les
mentalistes part du principe que la
pensée peut générer une réaction dans le
rouge à un petit peu comme le réflexe de
pavlov
et qu'est ce que c'est le réflexe de
pavlov écoutez je suis vous le dire
c'est très simple il vend petrovic
pavlov a démontré que si répéter le même
stimulus à chaque fois qu'ils
apportaient de la nourriture à un chien
comme par exemple sifflé dans un sifflet
un tel suspense alors à terme le fait de
faire ce stimulus sans forcément
apporter la nourriture en même temps
déclenché la syndication du chien mais
cet exemple c'était pour vous puissiez
bien comprendre l'idée parce qu'en
réalité le réflexe de pavlov est un
réflexe conditionné qu'on appelle
maintenant le conditionnement de pavlov
revenons-en au mentalisme je disais donc
les mentalistes part du principe que la
pensée que gm ait une réaction dans le
regard
oui j'ai honteusement repris le même
plan que tout à l'heure un détail près
ou pas ou alors j'ai fait mon feignants
on va y arriver je disais les
mentalistes part du principe que la
pensée peut générer une réaction dans le
regard mais c'est uniquement liée à
l'expérience des mentalistes et non à un
protocole scientifique
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'empirisme et je
vous propose une source dans la
description très intéressante et très
philosophique à ce sujet à ce jour ce
que les mentalistes pratique et donc de
manière empirique vient d'être validé
scientifiquement par des chercheurs du
laboratoire de psychologie cognitive et
par ceux du laboratoire parole et
langage du cnrs aix marseille université
ainsi que par l'université groningen du
pays bas et je sais pas si ça se
prononce comme ça ils ont démontré que
la taille des pupilles n'est pas
forcément lié qu'à la lumière ambiante
ou à l'intensité lumineuse de l'objet
qu'on regarde mais aussi et ça c'est
génial au mot utilisé à l'écrit comme à
l'oral
si je vous dis par exemple une grande
plage à midi baigné d'un soleil
éblouissant
alors votre pupilles va se contracter
même si vous êtes dans un endroit sont à
l'envers si je vous dis en pleine nuit
ou dans l'obscurité alors votre pipi va
donc réagir comme si elle était dans le
noir et se dilater pour quantifier
scientifiquement cela les chercheurs ont
donc fait lire puis entendre à 60
personnes
trente noms lumineux 30 mo on va dire
obscur et 30 mo neutre en termes de
luminosité comme ballon pob pouces bleus
je crois que ça s'est vu l'a1 est enfin
ils l'auront fait lire et entendre 20
noms d'animaux
en parallèle les chercheurs ont mesuré
la taille des pupilles des participants
oui parce que sinon ça n'avait aucun
intérêt de faire ça sur ce schéma vous
pouvez voir comment la pupille réagi
face à un mot évoquant une luminosité
faible ou élevée et voici quelques plans
que je me suis également amusé à filmer
en disant d'abord des mots lumineux puis
ensuite des mots sombre sachant plus que
pour faire ces scènes là nous étions en
pleine lumière
reste maintenant à répondre à une autre
question scientifiquement parlant
est-ce que les pensées et les images que
nous nous faisons mentalement sont
nécessaires à la compréhension d'un mot
là j'en ai déjà perdu 2,3 ou sentait
simplement une préparation de
l'organisme est donc une conséquence
indirecte
les chercheurs sont sur le coup et je
peux vous dire qu'ils cherchent c'est
que ça c'est le principe
en fait je suivrai ça de près je vous
tiendrai au courant si c'est intéressant
de voir que la science vient de valider
une technique de mentalisme parfois
celle inverse puisque en 2012
des chercheurs de l'université de
portsmouth avait invalidé l'un des
principes de la bnf en demandant à
trente et une personnes de parler de
leur vrai métier puis en leur demandant
de mentir consciemment et en s'inventant
un nouveau métier seulement 10% des
participants avaient fait quelque chose
qui aurait pu être prédits par la pnl au
niveau du mouvement de la direction de
leur regard c'est à dire que le postulat
de la bnf c'était de dire que ça partait
grosso modo vers la gauche qu'on allait
dans sa mémoire donc en disait la vérité
et vers la droite quand on allait dans
la créativité donc en inventer et c'est
là que vous est proposée à vous de faire
vous même l'expérience sur quelqu'un et
de mettre les résultats dans un tableau
que j'avais mis en ligne que si vous
étiez sûr de vos résultats alors on va
pas se mentir le protocole et léger bien
sûr il peut y avoir un billet de la part
de l'expérimentateur mais ces résultats
que je vous mets en libre accès aussi
dans la description ont le mérite
d'exister grâce à 5 158 d'entre vous
merci pour la première étape à savoir
dire son vrai métier cent cinquante et
une personnes ont regardé vers leur
gauche comme la pnl pu le prédire
soit 27 % des participants pour la
deuxième étape c'est le moment c'est
long on fait preuve de créativité 203
personnes ont regardé vers leur droite
non je me trompe 205 soit 37 % des
participants
alors les résultats sont quand même plus
satisfaisant que dans l'expérience sur
les trente et une personnes en 2012
mais il faut prendre en compte que notre
protocole fait à distance de cette
manière n'est pas très rigoureux
disons que ces résultats-là son
informatif et surtout le démontre qu'on
est loin de s'approcher d'un pourcentage
fiable de quelque chose qu'on pourrait
considérer comme étant fiable
en clair cette méthode peut donner au
mieux une piste a recoupé au minimum
avec deux autres méthodes plus fiable
que sinon on peut ranger clairement
cette théorie aux oubliettes
au rang des idées reçues que lui
abordons ce que vous m'avez appelé
pardon ça lui va bien
et donc comme je voulais annoncé je vous
mets les résultats des 558 participants
dans un tableau qui est dans la
description comme quoi c'est intéressant
de se tenir au courant des études qui
sont réalisés chaque jour en parlant
d'ailleurs de faire attention je n'ai
pas utilisé trois fois la même séquence
vidéo dans cette vidéo où on a
l'impression que je la réutilisent trois
fois en fait c'est un détail près à
chaque fois on verra dans les
commentaires si vous trouvez et j'ai une
surprise pour vous pour cette rentrée je
prends trois rendez vous avec vous vous
voyez monsieur oui mademoiselle une
nouvelle vidéo tous les mardis à 15
heures et tous les vendredis à 15 heures
oui à 15 heures donc ça c'est les deux
premiers les mardis et les vendredis à
15 heures est également un live à chaque
dernier mercredi du mois à 20h20 20h20
les vrais savent donc le prochain live
ce sera le 27 septembre à 20h20 et enfin
un jeu vraiment un truc interactif tous
ensemble j'espère que vous serez la
gérer n'oubliez pas vous pouvez vous
abonner même en cliquant sur ce petit
rond même depuis votre téléphone ou
votre tablette ça c'est possible et le
tlm maintenant on se retrouve les mardis
et les vendredis à 15 heures ciao
[Musique]